one night the box heard from yes I talk
too much going in the other kid you
might just want to talk
ok
Harvey no cell phones ponymon I don't
care if you have one on you and want it
you on your sisters to Angelo cell phone
yeah the other website to see little
pink Centauri is nigh smashing so don't
mess with these plays in atl into virgin
cell phone
the spectrum is that too good dinners to
know hope you got that move all figured
out um okay welcome everybody I think I
know everybody here but I'm Brad Rosen
one of the guys who does a little bit to
help manage the Chicago blaze it's my
pleasure to introduce Skokie mayor
George Randerson mayor Gunderson has
lived in skokie with his wife Susan who
joins us tonight and their two children
for over 25 years as well as a grandson
he served as a trustee to go to skokie
from 1984 until he was appointed mayor
in January of 1999 he's also an
answering faculty member at Oakland
Community College where he teaches us
ser government the mayor has also been a
driving force on many fronts to make
Sophie what most livable and
forward-thinking communities in the
Chicago area in the nation with no
further ado it's my distinct pleasure to
introduce let's go c'mere George me
inducing I'll share a couple words of
trustee Randy Roberts is also joined us
this evening it's a pleasure to have the
opportunity are in the thank all of you
for everything you do for a village of
skokie having the blaze play urine
skokie is important to us because we
consider ourselves to be at higher and
if you
these community and this certainly is
one of the most important things that
would that we do you bring a lot of
distinction to the village and I know
that you're all a great championship
players brad has told me about it and I
only wish my best day I could just play
one game as good as all of you play on a
normal day I used I play chess at one
time and it's one of the most wonderful
games ever devised by man the most
difficult so congratulations and thank
you and brad has asked me if I would
wish or put the pieces in their proper
place in pushing the ceremony upon this
is like the first it's like the opening
pitch I gotta do okay this is my
grandson inside was a budding chess
player good luck to the place
yeah you must be other like as far as I
can't want to see with school absolutely
there's only 14 cities across actually
since we work yes three teams actually
12 teams 12 cities around the country
could have team so it's what's in a card
am one and there's not really any Tony
yes I is
our class
honest with y'all right now
what's hot
oh you should review the head for that
one
Oh
watch it with me